-Hey, everybody.
We are joined now by
one of my favorite comedians
a great guy,
and he has a YouTube show
that he started this last month,
called "Dinner with the J-
Dinner with the Gaffigans.
It's "Gaffigan," right?
not "Jaffigan"?
-Sometimes it's Jaffigan.
[ Both laugh ]
-We're here with Jim Gaffigan.
Hi, Jim.
-Hi.
It's nice to talk to you.
I -- I'm not sure
exactly where you are,
but I am in downtown Manhattan
My wife is high-risk, so we ar
under double-secret quarantine
I am with my five children
We've been here for a month,
and they're still alive.
So I should get an award.
-You should get an award.
I mean,
don't take this the wrong way --
I've always thought
that you were a little crazy
that you have five children,
you travel with them
everywhere you go.
You're incredible
parents to them.
But you must be regretting i
a little bit right now.
-I'm absolutely regretting it.
I think if there's
one takeaway from this segment
it should be to encourage people
not to have children.
And if you have them,
give them away now.
No, I -- It's this thing
called distance learning,
which is -- obviously,
the schools have shut down
and distance learning
was created by people
that truly hate parents.
Because I have five kids,
so you'd think,
five kids, five screens,
five places
in a New York City apartment
But it's not even that.
It's five different schedule
for five different kids
on five different screens
in a New York City apartment
And the school, they just send
these kind of assignments, like,
"Hey, have your 7-year-old
do all this stuff."
I'm like, "I'm not doing this.
So I'm raising them
to be farmhands.
-You have -- I think, if I hav
it right, three boys, two girls?
Are they handling it
differently?
-The girls are civilized.
The boys, who only want
to play on iPads,
once it comes
to their distance learning
which is essentially
teleconferencing with a teacher,
that suddenly, they don't know
how to turn on a computer.
You know what I mean?
Or the iPad
is confusing to them.
But I understand,
it's difficult.
You know,
school without friends,
that's appealing, right?
-Right, sure.
Are they getting
their work done?
Are you a taskmaster with them
-You know, I --
I don't know.
It's too --
There's too many of them,
and there's too many
different projects.
You know, I think, yesterday
I spent two hours
trying to print from my son'
school iPad to our printer
So I know that I printed out
the assignment.
I don't know
what happened to it, though.
He'll be fine.
-So at the end of the day,
you don't sort of gather the
all around and say,
"Let's show me
what you've done?"
-Not really. No.
You know, eventually,
it gets to 6:00 p.m., we d
"Dinner with the Gaffigans,"
and then, I pretend to like them
for like 40 minutes
during the show.
By the way, we've done,
I think, 26 --
we've done a whole --
we've done 28 episodes.
-That's crazy.
-That's a whole season.
You know what I mean?
-That's like a season
back in like 1950.
-Right? I don't know
if we've been picked up.
I don't think -- I don't want us
to get picked up.
But there is --
you know, it's like --
And we don't really
have contracts,
so my kids could come back
and really have high demands
-Yeah, I think
you could threaten --
A lot of sitcoms
replace child actors.
-That's true.
-This is basically you jus
filming family and dinner.
Like, where did you
get this idea?
-I was on tour in Latin America.
I was in Bogotá, and I was about
to head to the theater,
and my manager called me
and informed me that Argentina
had closed its borders, so I
would not be going to Argentina.
And, you know,
things were moving fast.
So I decided to fly back hom
the next day.
And while I was at the airport
there was a --
You know, I was existing
with the knowledge
that I might not get back,
or I might be separated
from my family
for an extended time.
And so, the
"Dinner with the Gaffigans
was something that serves
as just --
'Cause I know that
there are some people
separated from their families,
or they're just by themselves.
I have friends
that are by themselves.
So it was just something light
and also, it would be somethin
to serve as a break
from the constant, you know,
consumption of news.
Like, I don't know
how many times --
I feel like, at this point
there's got to be three or fou
Sanjay Guptas,
because that poor guy,
he's working so hard.
-Yeah.
-And all those CNN anchors
they're like,
"My friend, Sanjay Gupta..."
He doesn't
like any of those people now
-[ Laughs ]
-They're like,
"Sanjay, can you be on my show?"
He's like, "I haven't slep
in three weeks."
No, but we wanted
"Dinner with the Gaffigans,"
which is streamed on YouTube
and it has
an interactive element,
so people can ask families
and we do charades
and stuff like that.
So it's totally
a distraction from, you know
what we're dealing with.
-I want to --
We're gonna put up a photo
of sort of a typical
"Dinner with the Gaffigans,"
and then, I want to put up
a second photo where
it looks as though
your youngest son
is wearing a Spider-Man mask
-Yes.
-So, was that
for the whole dinner?
-Well, there's different themes.
Not for the whole dinner.
But there's different themes
One -- and by the way, it's --
the enthusiasm from my childre
has disappeared.
I'm like, "Do you guys
want to dress up
since we're having bratwurst
Do you want
to do German things?"
And they're like,
"No, get outta here."
But there was a dress-up,
like, a superhero dinner,
and Patrick was the only one
that dressed up.
But what we've done recently
probably for the past
week or two,
is we've added a charity element
where we're attempting
to raise money
so that we can buy food trucks
for hospital workers
in New York City.
And, you know, obviously,
there's the PPE,
but like, on our YouTube,
there's this super chat
where if you donate $2,
your message gets highlighted.
And so, then we comment on it.
And sometimes
we make fun of the person
that donated
or make up a lie about them.
It's all very simple, nothing --
no huge,
high entertainment value.
But it's kind of comfort food.